so when i think about this if we go pull
up the chart uh for a second here and we
look at uh what is this like october
november of last year it just went
parabolic right literally from october
to november up until march we went from
about 10 uh 15 000 all the way up to 64
000. a lot of the same market dynamics
seem to be at play one we know that
there's lots of illiquidity in the
market but two is when you look at that
short term kind of price is there a
thought process as to how to measure the
severity of the move like could this
just be a 20 30 move or is it much more
likely to be um you know kind of
hundreds of percent upwards yeah so i
guess i would just think about it you
know when bitcoin breaks its former
all-time high it's just kind of sends a
message to the market it sends a message
to the world that this thing isn't dead
and whatever kind of preconceived notion
you had about bitcoin or it's a ponzi
scheme or it's worthless or or anything
else uh you know you see someone like
jamie dimon come out and harp on it for
years and all those clients are beating
down his door demanding it uh he's gonna
you know he's gonna have to enter the
market um and so that's just one example
but that's that's happening across the
world at scale across industries whether
it's energy banking uh technology
everybody's interested in it tim cook
just casually was like yeah i think it's
good for a diversified portfolio you
know stuff like that where apple has a
couple hundred billion dollars of cash
right i'm not saying apple has bought
any bitcoin but uh the whole world's
essentially short this asset class and
so you know they all everyone's looking
to get off zero um not everyone here is
uh in the world is bitcoin evangelists
like ourselves um and so they need to
get it you know they need to get off
zero they have you know basically zero
allocation and so they're the ones that
are on the bid when bitcoin's 67 68
grand you take the short-term and
long-term holder cost basis you have
this ratio explain what's happening here
yeah so this is just the same data but
it's just it's just put into a ratio and
so basically what you see what is the
the trend the green highlights uh our
bull markets but what i'm really
highlighting is when that ratio is going
down so when that ratio is going down
that's saying that uh the short term
holder cost basis is is trending
against the long-term holder cost basis
so you know that that short term holder
uh you know it's essentially the
realized price is the technical term for
it uh the average price of all these
utxos moving uh on chain but uh during
that green you know the green highlights
there what what's happening is that that
short term holder cost basis is bidding
against the long term uh holder cost
basis and that's happening because long
term holders essentially are cornering
the market um and so right you know you
can see if you go to the next slide
there we're just entering that kind of
that green phase which is which is that
you know basically a telltale sign of a
reflexive bull market got it and so when
we think about cornering the market one
of the things that uh i think people
don't understand about this is uh this
happens in all asset classes right so if
you think of like the art market is
probably the one that people talk about
the most where uh there's an auction
house the auction house knows that hey
uh joe is an amazing artist and so he
has 25 pieces that are out in the world
i'm gonna go buy 22 of them and i'm
going to hold them and then go tell
everyone in the world that joe's an
amazing artist there's only three pieces
of art that are trading kind of liquid
in the market and then over over time
since i've cornered that market what i'm
going to do is i'm going to slowly sell
into the market as the price uh goes
ahead and increases for his art so
that's an idea of cornering the market
very illiquid market very kind of
inefficient market because uh in in uh
art if we go to the stock market i
always use the example there was a stock
years ago or maybe nine years ago maybe
two years ago called tilray it was a
cannabis stock and literally it went
absolutely parabolic it was one of the
first cannabis stocks to actually trade
on the stock market but the other thing
about it was that uh they only floated a
very small percentage of the stock in
the market and the rest was held back by
uh investors and the team and so
naturally a bunch of people were bidding
into the market there was a little bit
uh available and the price exploded the
same market dynamics right here in
bitcoin right we don't think of it that
way because all the bitcoins in the
market but essentially the long-term
holders are holding everything illiquid
there's a little bit of float out there
now you have a bunch of demand
increasing because price is essentially
uh uh operating as like a marketing
function it's telling the world like you
said hey bitcoin's going bitcoin's going
more demand comes in and then that's
that reflexivity that you're talking
about is that like a fair way to
categorize this yeah 100 i mean
basically like what you have is is the
21 million hard cap i mean we're not
there yet it's like 18.9 million but
essentially it's this game theoretic uh
you know uh it's just it's this game
theory where all those around the world
the hodlers of last resort are saying
you know i'm a buyer at any price i'm
just going to acquire this thing because
i know you know
like that you can't fight this economic
reality um and so so i'm just going to
i'm just going to hoard this thing at
any dollar price
and understand that you know there's a
lot of people around the world doing the
same thing so you know
with absolute scarcity and with fiat
currency you know constantly uh debasing
uh the supply constantly increasing now
we know where this is going long term so
that's what you see over time you know
through the 80 boom and bust through
these parabolic cycles um essentially
bitcoin's monetizing all right so we've
got uh this slide four bitcoin vertical
institutional accumulation and i know
that you and others that have been
looking at on chain metrics willie wu uh
will clemente david puel et cetera you
guys are you guys are in your bag right
now because every time you guys are
sending out charts now it's overlaid
with tweets like yup i called it here's
the receipt uh so walk me through what's
going on in this chart
yeah i just i just you know link some of
these tweets there today i guess uh you
know maybe hindsight is 20 20 but uh if
you're just looking at the chart right
so this is since uh the middle of the
summer it's just up and to the right and
yes there are dips um sometimes the
market gets over leveraged but it's
pretty clear what's happening and yeah
retail is participating but for the most
part uh i would say i'm pretty confident
this is uh big money allocating capital
um you just kind of see uh just
basically a relentless bid um you know
up and up into the right any any dips
that come are pretty pretty short-lived
um and they just you know just kind of
get the wicks just get eaten right up
and i think that's a telltale sign of
institutional capital it's just in the
market every second of every day right
um you know you have retail plebs that
will you know buy 10 bucks a day 50
bucks a day 100 bucks a day well
i think there's billions of dollars of
capital that are that are buying you
know that have bots that are buying
every single second of the day um and
you know it's it's going to be a lot
harder for the next michael sailor to
come in and acquire 100 000 bitcoin
without without really moving the price
here um so you know i think that's
what's occurring and that's what's been
occurring since you know the summer at
around 30k